can't you just give Ben a key to the
city here now in your office where no
one will know your shame
sorry babe no worries
don't worry if people found out I gave
Wyatt the key to the city I would never
get reelected so
no
what are you doing there Wyatt
I'm feeding your eagle
he's starving
it's it's bronze babe why the eagle we
should go
oh hey there
I got you uh some waffles here courtesy
of JJ's Diner and chicken soup courtesy
of me I'll take the waffles thank you
so how did the rest of the meeting go
um well you said you needed 80 total
businesses to participate yeah
yeah we have 110. and Counting
so uh nice work Leslie nice work to you
too oh uh left the chicken soup there
just in case it's a
old Family Recipe it's not a big deal
but
thank you for that okay
oh I cannot wait for Leslie to see this
surprise I am so prepared I watched
Enchanted three times to get all the
details right and then another two times
because that movie is amazing oh it
really is hello oh hey Leslie uh you
want to go grab lunch together uh I'm
out front super casual
office I'm I'm out saving the merger can
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah no worries okay
great I'll see you at dinner I love you
boy well it's not too late to cancel the
waffle buffet or the Hillary
impersonator but a lot of these deposits
were non-refundable
hey Larry you up for a boys day out in a
horse-drawn carriage
sure
what the heck well thus begins our
Enchanted Adventure God that movie
really was amazing you know what doesn't
get enough credit in that movie this
music
good sir
from the movie that is definitely from
the movie I'm sorry
truth is they didn't ask me to introduce
you
I asked them if I could do it I was
going to talk about how I owe you so
much and I used to buy me through all my
failures and I stood by you through all
your terrible outfits but when I got up
there I got pretty emotional to make it
up to you
I'd like to read you the speech now
I've known a lot of ballers in my day
but no man balls harder than the man I'm
about to bring up
he's kind he's intelligent
he's the person I'm deeply proud to call
my friend it's pretty good speech I mean
it was
it was a little sappy Maybe
I think I liked it
kidney stone yep big sucker too we're
gonna have to keep him here until it
passes Leslie and Dr clipperton
wow man I I'm so glad you guys are
meeting it's like Worlds Collide you
know I love it
I want candy
what is he on morphine that's good stuff
Leslie come here do you have any idea
how beautiful you are I'm serious you're
like
a flower or no like a snug bug or like a
a snugger doodle or something like that
we should just
you know
life we have a ceremony we need to be at
in two hours is there anything that we
can do sorry Ice Town you're not going
anywhere for at least a day
okay well I'll call Mayor Stice and
we'll reschedule the ceremony no this
town expects me to wuss out I'm making
that speech and I'm simply going to
explain to the crowd that love is
everywhere and they have to surrender to
the flow of the universe you know Price
is Right is on I think
oh you remember staying home sick from
school
watching the prices right
oh God
excuse me
hi everything okay you want me to come
back to the hospital
I'm good at goody you just do your thing
baby Smurf I mean I wish you were here
it seems pretty fun and festive Town
mascot is here Fred the sled they only
bring
for special occasions
can't believe they're doing all this for
me
the universe is love
and sure my husband made an honest
mistake 20 years ago but it was very
meaningful that you were gonna hi Leslie
to forgive him if it's so meaningful to
him then where is he he is in the
hospital sir he has a calcified Rock
Lodge in his penis
so I know we agreed on no gifts but I
did get you a gift a bunch of them
actually I was going to surprise you
with them yesterday but they never
reached you
oh my Heaven God oh you planned all of
this for me an enchanted Carriage this
is amazing oh and your scrapbook
instincts are really good I mean this is
a little rough but you have a lot of
talent here I can't believe I actually
defeated Leslie Knope at a gift exchange
yes hey you want to see me I did think
back
Dr butt
I mean
why did you throw this in I just got off
the phone with our old boss from
Indianapolis and apparently there may be
some sort of a budget problem in
Eagleton he asked if maybe you and I
wouldn't have a look
U.N Butch counted in the Sundance Kid
together again
[Music]
I don't know I've been acting really
weird lately and um
I really like you what I'm about to say
is going to contradict the idea that I
really like you know just open the box
please stop bringing out the box okay
Leslie you're being really nice and what
I'm about to say is gonna make you hate
me okay then I'll just open the box for
you
wow
you knew
I figured it out a while ago
I'm sorry I should have told you I knew
but I just I wanted this to last as long
as possible
we have to break up
why
why do we have to break up well
lastly everything you've accomplished
you have earned and you have worked for
I don't want anyone to think that you
got where you are today by Sleeping with
your boss
but I really like sleeping with my boss
yeah
okay look I can make this really easy
for you
um
it's not you it's me
I'm not ready for a commitment I just
don't like you anymore and no it's hard
to hear that but
you're boring and frankly you disgust me
how did you figure it out let's see
there was a dude in the ladies Yacht
Club
yeah but I covered that pretty well also
you've been making campaign speeches in
your sleep
granted you always do that but
they got really specific and moving did
I have a good opening line
that was simple but I liked it
well my boyfriend might not be moving
back for a while so I have to back out
just wanted to look at it one more time
you know I can't give you your deposit
back I know and there's a 300 all right
Martha I get it
actually is there a way I could put down
like a
hey
hey you were coming back here huh
oh my God what are you doing
I'm thinking about my future
I am deeply
ridiculously in love with you and above
everything else I just I
I want to be with you forever
so Leslie Knope
wait wait okay just
I need to remember this sure give me a
second
hold on I need another second please I
need to remember
every little thing about how perfect my
life is right now
at this exact moment okay
are you good yeah okay I'm good
Leslie nope
yes
marry me oh yeah okay